foreign
[Music]
this week we keep bringing you the most
important news about your favorite
movies in series included are infos
about the upcoming Super Mario Brothers
movie an avatar series Hogwarts Legacy
and worrying news about Dune The
Sisterhood we also talk about a new
series for the horror movie it and
possible Sherlock Holmes 3 with Robert
Downey Jr have fun watching
the new movie adaptations of Stephen
King's It from 2017 and 2019 were huge
hits at the box office it was therefore
only a matter of time before further
projects featuring The Killer Clown
Pennywise would be announced now HBO Max
is getting ready to follow up on the
movie success with the series welcome to
Dairy after Insider information was
leaked in March of 2022 that it would
continue it has now become official
Pennywise is returning responsible for
the new it series is among others the
director of the Remake Andy mushietti
says that the book was far too complex
to include all the interesting aspects
of Stephen King's stories in the films
the series which you will also direct
for some episodes is expected to make up
for that together with his sister
Barbara mushietti and writer Jason Fuchs
welcome to Dairy has the same team
working on it as it and it chapter 2.
together both films generated more than
1.1 billion US Dollars worldwide and
with their portrayal of the evil clown
Pennywise created a modern horror icon
that is in no way inferior to its
predecessor from 1990 played by Tim
Curry it is not yet known whether Bill
Skarsgard will once again slip into the
character's costume in the series
welcome to Derry is being produced by
HBO Max and Warner Brothers television
we are eagerly awaiting further news
especially regarding a prospective
release date
at the last Super Bowl there was a spot
for the popular Super Mario Brothers
movie since then many fans have been
eagerly awaiting more news about Mario
and Luigi's newest Adventure after all
the movie's release is not too far off
as Universal Pictures surprisingly
announced the waiting time will be
shortened a little for the fans of the
Italian plumber as in the countless
video games that have long been world
famous the story revolves around the
adventurous journey of Mario and
Princess Peach to an underground maze
the goal is to rescue Mario's brother
Luigi who has been kidnapped by the
ruthless and fearsome Bowser and is now
being held captive as can be seen in the
trailer all sorts of characters from the
Super Mario universe will make an
appearance including Donkey Kong Cranky
Kong toad as well as the villain Bowser
and his henchmen more information will
be available at an upcoming Nintendo
Direct event on March 9th where among
other things they will show the final
trailer and get everyone excited before
the release meanwhile we are already
looking forward to the early theatrical
release on April 5th 2023.
the video game Hogwarts Legacy is a huge
success both fans of The Wizarding World
as well as more experienced players have
a lot of fun playing the game now there
are first rumors that a Hogwarts Legacy
series is already in the works the game
was released at the beginning of
February for both PC and consoles the
developer Avalanche was able to reach
even those who otherwise have nothing to
do with Harry Potter or other spin-offs
thanks to its atmospheric world and its
fun combat system meanwhile over 12
million copies of the game have been
sold resulting in revenues of
approximately 850 million dollars which
is extremely high for a video game
particularly when you consider that
shortly before the release people were
calling for a boycott because of the
author of the books JK Rowling was
accused of being transphobic however the
vast majority of players were not
bothered by this in fact it was reported
this week that fans of the School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry could soon be
treated to a new series according to
Giant freaking robot a Hogwarts Legacy
series for the streaming service HBO Max
is currently in the works this would
keep the series in control of the movie
Giant Warner Brothers which is the owner
of the game developer Avalanche it also
suggests that the entire Fantastic
Beasts film series may be scrapped after
the moderate success of the third
installment so that the company can move
on to a top-notch series as far as story
is concerned this could mean that the
Hogwarts Legacy series like the video
game will be set in the 19th century in
other words well before the Harry Potter
books and the Fantastic Beasts movie
series apart from the recent rumor which
is said to come from a well-informed
Insider there is no further information
about the Hogwarts Legacy adaptation the
popularity of the game however is a good
indicator that original projects aside
from Harry Newt and others can also be
successful we'll keep you up to date as
always
nowadays there is little that represents
Blockbusters as much as James Cameron's
Avatar franchise currently Avatar the
way of water is breaking all kinds of
records and many are eager to find out
how the franchise will continue one
option is becoming ever more likely an
avatar TV series back in December
Cameron was still rather reluctant to
talk about a series adaptation in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter he
said that he wasn't really interested
because the technical obstacles for
depicting Pandora were simply too great
he added that one would have to take
another look in 10 years when
time-saving methods such as deep
learning have advanced further after the
success of Avatar 2 at the box office
the director seems to have had a change
of heart in an interview with the Los
Angeles Times he maintained that a
series would not make sense at this time
he did lower the waiting period for a
possible series to five years indeed it
is comprehensible that Avatar cannot
simply be adapted into a series for one
thing the running time and the
associated amount of CGI shots is a lot
bigger than for feature films meaning
the costs would be even higher than for
the already crazy expensive theatrical
Blockbusters just part 2 alone cost 350
million dollars for a running time of
192 minutes A series would struggle a
lot more to make up for these costs
moreover the vast worlds of Pandora are
certainly perfectly suited for the
overwhelming experience on a big screen
but with the home screens be able to
keep up it took Cameron 13 years to make
the Avatar sequels and hardly anyone
will be better acquainted with the
technology involved we are eager to find
out how close we really are to an avatar
series when he tells us that we can ask
for it again in five years so in the
meantime we are rather looking forward
to the upcoming feature films Avatar 3
will be released on December 20th 2024.
nowadays many people associate Sherlock
Holmes with the series starring Benedict
Cumberbatch in a total of four seasons
he and fellow actor Martin Freeman were
able to convincingly perform their roles
and played a large part in ensuring that
the setting worked since it was Modern
compared to the book however many fans
are still waiting for another sequel to
the movies with Robert Downey Jr in the
classic setting the reasons for the
waiting period are now becoming a little
clearer although the first movie was
released before the series in 2009 it
became very quiet around the franchise
after the second part Sherlock Holmes a
game of shadows was released two years
later a sequel was announced
half-heartedly over and over again only
to be postponed in the end the busy
schedule of Downey Jr who in the
meantime repeatedly impersonated the
superhero Iron Man in the MCU did not
make for a quick production of the
sequel now the US magazine collider has
published some statements by director
Guy Ritchie the 54 year old Brit
directed both films with Downey Jr and
to all appearances is very interested in
making a third film as a producer
according to his own words it is
entirely up to Downey Jr who was in
charge of the entire project Richie said
he has stepped back from all matters of
detail until he gets the go-ahead for
the production with Dexter Fletcher a
new director has already been found he
has directed the two biopics Bohemian
Rhapsody and Rocket Man for example but
is Downey Jr even interested in the
project according to his last statement
from 2020 not only does he want to
produce a third film but he also wants
to establish an entire universe with
spin-offs in series two of them have
recently been in the works at HBO Max
but they are said to be without Downey
Jr as Sherlock we can't wait to hear
more news about Sherlock Holmes 3 and
other projects
at first glance Frank Herbert's novel
series Dune offers everything required
to serve as a basis for a major movie
and series franchise a well-liked novel
series two successful feature films to
date as well as an upcoming sequel not
to mention an extensive storyline that
can be adapted in a variety of ways the
planned series Dune The Sisterhood
should also have caught the wave of
success but apparently there are some
serious issues that are currently
delaying production last Tuesday
deadline reported that current director
Johann rank who also worked on the
acclaimed Chernobyl recently revealed
his departure from the project this is
concerning because part of the filming
has already been done and thus a large
part of the production was carried out
under ranked supervision officially
creative disagreements are said to have
been the reason deadline fleshes it out
with an inside reporter that the
director's Vision did not match that of
HBO Max Executives above all the look of
the series is said to have deviated too
much from Dennis villenev's feature film
furthermore the Dune the sister her team
will have to do without actress Shirley
Henderson in the future the 57 year old
who once played Moaning Myrtle in the
Harry Potter Saga was supposed to assume
one of the leading roles the main focus
of the film is on the mysterious
Sisterhood which is considered to be the
predecessor organization of the later
important Benny Jesuit in the series set
10 000 years before villenev's film
adaptation they are confronted with
powerful individuals who want to take
over the fate of the entire universe
thus a recasting of Henderson's role
would have to occur in order to tell the
existing story it is also believed that
extensive reshoots will have to take
place to properly produce the series it
is even possible that the series will
have to start from scratch so as to
create a clear distinction between the
old director and the new one whether the
almost simultaneous departure of the
director and the leading actress might
even signify the end of the series as
not yet known there is still no official
statement from Warner Brothers on the
current rumors once there is new
information we will let you guys know
thank you
in addition to all the news about
upcoming movies and series projects we
are happy to present you all the
animation highlights in our newest
original episode where we talk about all
the animated movies coming out in 2023
and 2024. make sure to check it out also
feel free to share your thoughts on the
news in the comments and give the video
a thumbs up if you enjoyed it thank you
all for watching and we'll see you next
time
[Music]
thank you